Intensivstation Uniklinik Tübingen vor
fünf Jahren überstand Julia Held hier
eine schwere OP wegen einer chronischen
Entzündung mussten ihr Teile des Darms
entfernt werden eine lange Leidenszeit
in der sie oft die übliche
Krankenhauskost bekam für Julia hält
geschmacklos und minderwertig
[Musik]
brauchte sie durchgehend eine speziell
auf sie zugeschnittene künstliche
Ernährung nur damit hätte ihr Körper
genug Mineralstoffe aufgenommen weil sie
die aber nicht immer bekam nahm sie
immer mehr ab
es war auch jeden Tag die Angst da wenn
es wieder zum Wiegen ging dass die Zahl
noch mal niedriger geworden ist in
Absprache mit Ärzten verzichtete sie
sogar ganz auf künstliche Ernährung ihr
Gewicht sank von 55 auf 37 Kilo das ist
nicht gut gegangen also mir ging es dann
noch am Tag der Entlassung am Abend so
schlecht dass ich direkt wieder im
Krankenhaus aufsuchen musste also mir
war richtig übel ich habe nur noch
erbrochen und ich konnte nichts mehr bei
mir behalten auch in anderen
Krankenhäusern die Sieger nach immer
wieder aufsuchen musste bekam sie keine
auf Sie zugeschnittene Nahrung doch
Julia hält bekommt selten Hilfe sondern
erlebt häufiger das gleiche sie solle
sich nicht zu anstellen
ich habe noch mal drauf aufmerksam
gemacht dass ich eine künstliche
Ernährung benötige da habe ich aber auch
die Erfahrung gemacht
dass ich einfach nicht so ernst genommen
wurde dass man meistens gesagt hat naja
das Warten jetzt mal ab ob sie
tatsächlich abnehmen und es ging einmal
so weit dass eine Ärztin mir tatsächlich
Apfel hingestellt hat und gesagt hat ja
dann essen sie doch den dann brauchen
sie auch keine Infusion dabei sind die
Risiken falsche Ernährung in
Krankenhäusern seit langem bekannt
verlangsamte Heilprozesse Rückschläge
und allgemeine Entkräftung bis hin zum
Tod besonders gefährdet sind kovid und
krebs-
Schätzung mehrere medizinische
Fachgesellschaften in Deutschland
sterben ca 20 bis 30% aller
Krebspatienten nicht an ihrem Tumor
sondern an den Folgen einer
Mangelernährung das sind rund 55
000 Todesfälle jährlich allein bei Krebs
kaum zu glauben tot im Krankenhaus durch
falsche Ernährung dagegen helfen nur so
die Experten der Einsatz von besonderen
Ernährungsteams so wie seit einigen
Jahren an der Uniklinik Tübingen wo sich
Julia hält heute zur Nachkontrolle
vorstellt
Dr Michael Adolph und sein
Ernährungsteam konnten damals bei ihr
schwerste Schäden gerade noch mal
abwenden dr Adolf setzt so ein
Expertenteam inzwischen dauerhaft ein
auch wenn die Krankenkassen dafür nichts
zahlen das heißt unsere Tätigkeit wird
tatsächlich aus dem Gesamterlös des
Klinikums aus dem gesamten Pool der
Fallpauschalen derzeit quasi mit
finanziert das ist im Moment sehr
glücklich darüber und das kann nicht die
Zukunft sein
heute arbeitet dieses Team von
Ernährungsfachkräften auf allen
Stationen wo Risikopatienten sein
könnten in enger Zusammenarbeit mit
Ärztinnen und Ärzten arbeiten sie daran
Mangelernährung erfolgreich zu bekämpfen
Routine mäßig prüft die erdassistentin
daniela schweik hat bei einem
Krebspatienten ob bei ihm Anzeichen für
eine unzureichende Ernährung zu finden
sind einen Hinweis gibt die
handkraftmessung bei solchen besuchen
bespricht sie mit den Patienten immer
wieder welche Ernährung am besten helfen
kann bisher allerdings sind
Ernährungsteams wie an der Uniklinik
Tübingen die selten Ausnahme
dadurch will man immer ein bisschen an
Gewicht verlieren und plötzlich geht es
dann ganz schnell also für uns ist es
unvorstellbar dass wir das dass es noch
Krankenhäuser gibt die kein
Ernährungsteam haben und solche
Patienten die mit sehr komplexen
Fragestellungen kommen behandeln können
und wir denken auch dass es eine sehr
große Gefahr ist diese Patienten eben
dahin gehen nicht zu betreuen
tatsächlich leiden nach Schätzungen
medizinische Fachgesellschaften von
jährlich rund 17 Millionen Patienten
mehr als 3 Millionen an einer
unentdeckten Mangelernährung in dem
Sprung bedeutet das für den Patienten
natürlich und das ist mir wichtig zu
betone eine deutliche Verschlechterung
persönlichen Lebensqualität und das ist
deswegen wichtig weil wir ja für
Patienten da sind
es hat aber auch Auswirkungen für das
krankenhaussystem ausgelöst und diese
Kommunikation bedeutet Diagnostik und
Therapie Liegezeit und das belastet das
Krankenhaus Budget aus meiner Sicht
völlig unnötig
das Erleben auch Matthias zöpke und
seine Kollegen im Verband der
Diätassistenten immer wieder treffen sie
auf Patienten die im Krankenhäusern
falsch ernährt wurden für ihn nicht
nachvollziehbar denn seit mehr als zehn
Jahren gibt es bei vielen Krankheiten
Qualitätsstandards um Mangelernährung zu
verhindern zum Beispiel
bei Krebserkrankungen bei allen
Erkrankung am Verdauungssystem also zum
Beispiel Bauchspeicheldrüsenentzündung
als auch die chronischen Erkrankung was
den dünn und Dickdarm betrifft
aber auch bei neurologischen
Erkrankungen also Erkrankungen des
Nervensystems parken sondern als relativ
bekannt aber auch natürlich demenzielle
Erkrankung
weniger als 15% aller Krankenhäuser
verfügen über ein Ernährungsteam also
nicht einmal 300 von rund 2000
das hat mittlerweile auch der Gemeinsame
Bundesausschuss GBA erkannt dieses
Gremium entscheidet welche Leistungen
gesetzlich Versicherten bezahlt werden
im Juli 2022 beschloss der GBA Maßnahmen
gegen Mangelernährung lediglich zu
erproben dabei ist im Ausschuss selbst
klar
in Deutschland werden die Therapie und
Diagnostik der Mangelernährung nicht
speziell vergütet und daher verfügen
derzeit nur wenige krankenhaushäuser
über auf ernährungsspezialisiertes
Fachpersonal oder ein Ernährungsteam
heißt im Klartext kein Geld keine
Ernährungsteams trotzdem hat er
Gemeinsame Bundesausschuss nichts zur
Finanzierung beschlossen
hier muss von der politischen Ebene in
Deutschland Hilfe kommen wir brauchen
tatsächlich ich sage ganz bewusst Druck
erst wenn Geld im System dafür zur
Verfügung stehen wird wenn wir vorwärts
kommen auf Anfrage von Frontal zu einer
möglichen Finanzierung sieht das
Bundesgesundheitsministerium keinen
Handlungsbedarf schriftlich teilt es mit
Zitat
die Bundesregierung plant nicht
verpflichtende Ernährungsteams in
Kliniken vorzuschreiben die Kliniken
sind im Rahmen ihrer Organisationshoheit
selbst für die Verpflegung im
Krankenhaus verantwortlich
so bleibt Hilfe für Patientinnen wie
Julia hält den Zufall überlassen
die Kontakt zu den Elektroden gut ist
die erdassistentin Daniela Schweikert
Mist Muskel und Fettmasse im Körper so
kann sie erkennen ob ihre
Ernährungstherapie anschlägt
Mangelernährung im Krankenhaus ein
unterschätztes Problem das auch mit dem
Beschluss des Gemeinsamen
Bundesausschusses nicht gelöst wird der
will ohne gesicherte Finanzierung
Ernährungsteams bis 2028 lediglich
erproben
danach erfolgt aber so wie wir wissen
eine eine Auswertung was wieder mehrere
Jahre kostet die Patienten leiden jetzt
darunter Patienten versterben aufgrund
der mangelernährungssituation und fürs
gesamtgesundheitssystem Laufen natürlich
auch jetzt schon hochende Kosten auf das
ist absolut unverantwortlich und hier
müsste tatsächlich aus meiner Sicht die
politische Ebene aktiv werden in
Deutschland und hier sehe ich konkret
auch das Bundesministerium für
Gesundheit in Person auch in Lauterbach
in der Pflicht sich der Thematik endlich
einmal anzunehmen und deutliche Impulse
zu setzen sie ist fast am Krankenhaus
Essen gestorben ein Ernährungsteam hat
ihr das Leben gerettet seit kurzem kann
Julia hält sogar fast normal essen jetzt
hofft sie bald wieder arbeiten zu können